hi i'm joanna smith and today we're
looking at how to keep your employees
connected and engaged
even when they can't be in the office
co-workers and teams are able to stay
connected while working remotely
thanks to tools like collaborative
documents video meetings and team chat
rooms
on a larger scale enabling employees to
feel connected across teams
and to the company as a whole can be a
challenge one tactic that's especially
effective here is to host a virtual all
hands
an all hands meeting is unique in its
ability to bring an organization
together
while ensuring that everyone receives
the same information
in fact a recent study by igloo software
found that 75 percent of remote workers
believe they miss out on important
information
this can cause operational issues and
result in a disengaged workforce
but the logistics of running an all
hands meeting remotely may seem daunting
fortunately you can use google meet to
host a virtual all hands for up to a
hundred thousand employees
whether they're working from their home
the office on the factory floor
or out in the field google meet is our
enterprise grade video conferencing
solution that takes advantage of google
cloud's secure by design infrastructure
and features a number of proactive
counter abuse protections to help
protect your data and safeguard your
privacy
with google meet your video meetings are
secure easy to join and offer helpful
features like adaptive layouts
so that you can focus on what matters
most best of all
with google workspace you get so much
more than meetings
you can schedule and join meetings
directly from gmail or google calendar
easily present your screen or
collaborate on a document during the
meeting
and securely record a meeting and have
it saved to google drive to be shared
later
these same features that make google
meet so effective as a video
conferencing solution
are what make it simple and
straightforward to host a virtual all
hands meeting
so let's take a look at how that might
come together first we'll need to create
the calendar event for our all hands
we'll select the time and then we can
fill out the initial information
including the event title and any
details we need in the description
then we need to add google meet video
conferencing which is as simple as a
click
our all hands is also going to offer a
live stream so to enable that
we'll want to switch to the event
details page the option to add a live
stream is nested under the google meet
additional details view
and all it takes is a single click now
we can invite our co-presenters and
attendees and just like that
our virtual all hands has been scheduled
a single google meet video conference
supports up to 250 participants
while a live stream supports up to 100
000 viewers
depending on the size and nature of your
all hands you may want to create two
separate events
one that contains the google meet video
conference to which you only invite
presenters
and then a second event for the
view-only live stream where you can
invite attendees
creating a view-only event is a simple
edit on the initial event
from the event details dialog click the
three-dot menu button
and select create view only event you
can then invite your attendees and even
modify the event description
if there is separate information to
share for the audience
[Music]
on the day of the event we'll want to be
sure that everyone can join
whether they are using shared video
conferencing devices the google meet
mobile app
or watching the view only live stream
from any modern browser
as the event organizer will want to join
early so that we can turn on each of
these features
the live stream doesn't begin
automatically and needs to be started
this allows organizers to get set up and
test their presentations without
an accidental audience whenever one is
ready we'll click start streaming
we'll know the live stream is active
based on the live tag in the corner of
the screen
if we want to make this virtual all
hands available after the event
we can choose to record the meeting to
begin recording select the three dots in
the bottom corner to open a menu of
additional options
there we can click record meeting and
another red tag has appeared
in the upper corner to indicate that
this meeting is being recorded
the recording will be emailed to the
organizer after the live stream ends
and saved securely to google drive where
it can later be distributed for
on-demand viewing
to stop recording or streaming simply
return to the options menu
also from this menu we can turn on live
captions to make the meeting more
inclusive
live captions in google meet are powered
by google speech recognition technology
not typed by a human which helps ensure
no one outside your organization is
viewing private content
during the all hands each presenter can
easily participate
even if they aren't in the same place
when it's our turn to present we're
given the option to share our entire
screen
a specific window or even a single
chrome tab
which makes it easy to play high quality
videos with audio
and when we're done we simply stop
presenting with these options meet makes
it easy to have control of the content
you'd like to share
with distributed teams it's especially
important to have a mechanism in place
for getting feedback
after the all hands ends we'll use
google forms to quickly create a simple
survey
we can customize the format randomize
the questions and designate certain
questions as required
so employees can share their thoughts on
the event and content
because of the deep integrations built
into google workspace
the survey responses automatically
populate into a google sheet
where we can view the raw responses or
use the explore feature to get
suggestions on pivot tables or data
visualizations
the feedback form along with the
recording presented slides and follow-up
materials
can be shared across the company using
an internal portal created with google
sites
this internal site provides a quick and
easy way to keep everyone on the same
page
and serves as an on-demand reference for
their content a site like this is
especially helpful when onboarding new
employees
and it's easy to update so you can keep
adding additional content as it becomes
available
and that is how you can use google
workspace and google meet
to host a virtual all hands to keep your
employees connected
and engaged to learn more about google
workspace
visit workspace.google.com
you